everything's broken and breaking and i
love it when uh you know we pulled up
the polls last week uh
you probably won't be surprised by this
olivia the majority of democrat voters
believe the economy is fairly good
the majority of independent and
republican voters think the economy is
either very bad or fairly bad yeah what
about what's happening has these
democrats being like this is fine but
they're not paying any attention there
you go you know they're just not looking
at it these are the people who are in
their homes they've barely left these
are the double maskers you know who
watch rachel maddow that's true and are
probably still scrubbing their
groceries for goodness sake it's a it's
insane the real issue too i mean there's
so many real issues but what happens
when it doesn't work you know when
people still don't get vaccinated wait
wait wait wait wait
whatever we did the past year it didn't
work cases are surging
there are talks there's talks about
lockdowns maybe we won't lock down but
we got to wear masks again
it's still not going to work so how much
are we going to give away and my
favorite argument too is the people who
are like you know we've given up our
rights in the past so what are you
complaining about now it's really it's
really not that big a deal and it's like
well maybe we should have not resistance
is futile rights in the past as well
maybe we should not have capitulated to
these authoritarian ideologies well
previously um i got out of the cities
you did get out of the city you didn't
i didn't nope i
i did not so well this is interesting
though because
there's two things i want to hit at
first we we briefly mentioned a little
bit of the new york stuff but what i've
been saying for the past couple of
months is that it's like you're in a
house and the garage starts on fire and
you're like i'm in the living room who
cares and i'm like
yeah okay but the other issue is more
importantly
you could argue if i'm sitting in my
living room and the garage catches fire
i can go put the fire out the problem is
you've got other people in your house
holding you back saying there's no fire
stop
and that's the new york voter base
that's that should be a meme that should
be that dog meme you know the dog name
is trying to put the fire out this is
fun that should be part of it yeah my uh
look i love new york city i've always
loved new york city i always wanted to
live there my whole life my
great-grandparents came from italy to
new york city when i went like in 1911
or something like that my grandparents
were born in little italy my mom was
born in brooklyn
i was born in jersey because my parents
were in law school there my son was born
in brooklyn
i love new york city new york city is
like
uh
these kinds of restrictions and rules
will make new york city not what it is
when i go out recently right so
um washington square park's downtown and
we've written about this also post
millennial there's been like a lot of
um police crackdowns at washington
square park i was down there one night
over what uh you know they just don't
like the kids they don't want the kids
having fun is the way i see it i talk to
some residents and people who live in
greenwich village which used to be like
a super artsy neighborhood and is now
basically just nyu's campus and so it's
like a lot of rich professors
um in their
nyu housing or whatever and they don't
like having people in the park past
midnight so the cops can bound they
close the park after midnight they try
and kick everybody out and when you walk
through washington square park these
days at night
it's kind of great it's kind of like it
was in the 90s right like there's a lot
of kids
making out making a mess getting high
like screwing around you know like
it reminds me of my misspent youth which
i like and then the cops come in and
shut it down but
that kind of new york um
and also in the east side on the lower
east side people are always out they're
unmasking they're all you know they're
like having a good time
none of that can last with these kind of
restrictions none of that can um
continue the art scene can't continue
with that and arts culture also has been
so incredibly co-opted by
authoritarianism at this point you know
it's propaganda they just like do
exactly what they're told they create
the kind of work that they're told
yeah that's the people uh in new york
and how they vote i mean it's yes it is
i'm continually impressed by the
cognitive dissonance of
the tv says x one day and then why the
next day but they're both consistent i
just love these memes that are going
around where it's like these blue check
people tweeting things like you know
during trump why would anyone trust the
federal government and then there's one
guy and he's literally saying give me
the booster every single day into my
veins now they love it now they love the
federal government
it's insane so yeah so
so they're they're voting the uh how do
you how do you save us this is a thing
look a lot of people are like don't
leave the city's tim stay and fight and
i'm like dude new york's like 20 percent
conservative and i don't even i'm not
even saying conservatives have all the
like have the right answer it's just the
only alternative and there's nothing
there's nothing and and there aren't any
options right i mean i'm
i'm a registered democrat in new york so
that i can vote in the primary because
other like who cares about the mayoral
primary on the on the republican ticket
it just doesn't matter
uh eric adams was on the ticket and it
was actually fascinating to see how many
like to see that eric adams won that
primary he was the i mean he's
democratic party machine so yes he's far
leftist etc but he was the most
conservative one on the ticket and
people were shocked that minorities
voted for eric adams instead of maya
wiley who was like
you know oh progressive and we're like
eating rainbow puke and all of that
stuff but this is this is just
losing it's losing so yeah do i want to
leave cities no i love cities you are
partially right though
um but i did fall in love with dallas
recently
which was amazing i was down there um
covering cpac with post-millennial and i
kind of
loved i
really loved dallas um
so a couple of things one
it was really non-judgmental
so a lot of guns i don't i didn't see a
lot of guns but maybe that's part of it
maybe that just keeps everyone polite
and what are they saying society is a
polite society you know um but the
people i met were very nonjudgmental
very just like open and like hey what's
up i would say like people would say
like oh you know what are you doing here
i'd be like i'm here for work nobody
asked me what i did for a living know
and cared i respect that
i've lived i've spent my entire life in
the northeast
where
who your family is matters where you
went to school matters what your job is
matters like all of these little things
matter and the only thing that doesn't
really matter is who you are personally
and individually you know all that
matters is like the trappings of who you
are
and in dallas it wasn't like that um
there was this great neighborhood called
deep ellum where i went out drinking
pretty much every night which i really
that was fun but another thing that i
liked too uh
was that it wasn't a big city but it
didn't have these same kind it didn't
feel like it had these same kind of
constraints oh i mean texas is open
isn't it yeah texas is pretty open i was
in houston last week which was different
than
the dallas um
houston is a little more
it felt like a little more glam i think
it's also not as walkable dallas was
very walkable city
which i liked like i could walk to all
of the places i wanted to go
um
another thing i like too though just
you know and maybe it's just because i
spent my whole life in the northeast and
it's changing so quickly into something
that
where i don't feel comfortable where i
where i don't feel like i can be part of
life there like when i was in texas
i've never spent i've never spent like
any time in the south ever in my life
like i've been to florida when i was
eight i think we went to um the beach in
the carolinas you know
i don't know like i was there's a
picture of me in a bathing suit like i
don't really know what's going on uh i
remember the condo was cold that's it so
i've never spent any time in south and
then
it was amazing to have absolutely no
point of reference
like there were no memories anywhere
there were no in new york everywhere i
go like every street i walk down every
corner you know it's like oh i remember
that i remember that i was recently
walking with friends and i realized that
we you know we kept passing theaters
where i'd had work performed and you
know i don't do theater anymore
um but i was like every time i was like
oh crushing a little crushing a little
crushing
nothing like that
in dallas which also is open and free
and comfortable and people are
non-judgey and
you know maybe
maybe i can
i don't know maybe i can make a new life
i'm also i'm really interested in moving
the post-millennial to a southern state
so we've been kind of talking about that
um i hear tennessee is great tennessee
got to visit tennessee i would say yeah
tennessee or kentucky or west virginia
so i'm i'm yeah i'm open but what sort
of mar like what i keep marveling at is
that i've never been open to leaving the
northeast in my entire life
like ever and now i'm just like oh my
god
put me in my car and drive south but
look who's being driven out so you
mentioned you know a lot of people who
left new york were like wealthy it was
like um upper class sure lower upper
class it's you know not necessarily
people who are millionaires but well
they were able to keep their apartments
the people who moved no the millionaires
oh right right right exactly they just
went to their other house exactly the
ultra rich were like i'm gonna go stay
in mother's vineyard for a little while
like obama they party with him exactly
exactly but a lot of people were like
we're moving and they had the ability to
move very quickly so they're well off
but not necessarily the ultra rich or
anything like that they're leaving but
you're not ultra rich or anything and
now you're leaving nope yeah so they're
driving away you they're homogenizing
the city the only people who are going
to stay are going to be
die hard authoritarians who are just
like whatever de blasio says i will do
no matter what and they do or the really
poor
the people who can't leave
will now live unformed yeah and then
yeah and then the new york city public
school system which i watched uh
decades of rebuilding
and so that like you know
my friends who have money were sent who
could afford private school were sending
their kids to public schools
um i sent my child to a public school
after his private school closed uh
i can't afford the private schools in
new york city it's like 45 000 a year
ridiculousness plus they're trash i mean
the that's the other piece is they are
trash um at the end of the school year
this year a couple of my son's teachers
uh i want to say came out to me as
conservative oh wow and they were like
we really like what you've been doing
there's too many people who do that
sorry it's not you know and they should
just speak up now they're in teachers
unions they were handing me maya wiley
flyers or whatever it was wow and they
were like we have to hand you this and i
was like i'm not voting for you you know
i've had my own wiley i've had antifa
people do it to me when i was in
portland
i had black block masked auntie walker
may be like dude we love your stuff
and then i was like what are they doing
they're serving the machine yes serving
the machine there are people who
well to be fair
there's probably
the people who are talking to me were
like i like that you try to at least you
know give the information but we still
don't like those guys so they can say oh
you're cool you're all right but they're
still zealots and that's it's still a
problem but when we have tons of people
i can't tell you how many emails we get
where it's like i really wish i could
say something but i can't i'm like dude
then we're screwed we're screwed i agree
with you i get those emails too from
people who you know were in theater and
that i've worked with and they're like
oh i'm still trying to hang out to my
theater career and i'm like cash it in
dude well chuck it start over let's do
something else but and everyone always
responds it's easy to say
you know when you don't have kids
because they're these people have kids
you've got a job that you can move with
that actually you yeah your cultural
positions benefit your career a lot of
people don't have that and i'm still
saying dude look i get it i don't have
kids but i can tell you this i'm worried
about the future for the next generation
because people won't speak up and defend
their kids that's right if you're not
going to defend your children and the
world they live in then you're you're
giving them trash
so as for uh leaving new york i will say
i say get out of the cities and a lot of
people are like tim but what about texas
and what about florida i'm like good
point miami is pretty cool the weather
is brutal the weather seems the weather
is like it's like you might as well go
live under the sea it's like humid and
raining all the time but desantis is
doing a pretty good job with the state
they're they're coming out and saying
like oh the covey and all this crazy
stuff and i'm like
at this point if people have the the
opportunity to get the vaccines they
don't want to do it i don't know what a
country is supposed to do if you like
you know i guess de blasio forced people
to do it thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you